have you ever competed yourself in any
other tournaments
just just the fortnite stuff I think was
right I was gonna do a Pokemon go uh
tournament earlier this year just for a
meme for a little throwback meme because
they've actually got like a competitive
aspect to that now could you be
competitive in Pokemon go oh because you
can you can battle each other now yeah
dude I actually ironically play I I
stopped playing I think about a year or
so ago yeah yeah like in the middle of
the pandemic like yeah when the pandemic
started I was like well I can't go
outside so I can't really play it she's
a panda must have murdered Pokemon yeah
they I don't know what they did they did
something that allowed you to go to
pokestops without physically being there
yeah I think so okay does that remove
the whole point of Pokemon go yeah but
no one could go outside yeah so they had
to do they had to do something whatever
the game just died but I remember when I
was still playing it they introduced
like uh yeah basically like a battle
system where like you could pick like
three Pokemon right um and then based on
your uh was it uh what was the power
scaling cold in Pokemon go again
CP right that's it yeah yeah which is
the worst yeah
so it's like it's like you you've taken
three Pokemon and then your CP would
actually just account I think for like
the HP or something and then you
basically just like battle it out see
you know who gets off screen yeah tap
the screen you know like yeah it has
competitive things it's like it's like
the it's like the VGC game it's like
right kind of random but kind of skill
like you know this could work or what
moves are they running is like the
biggest competitive depth there's not
much competitive depth to it at all
which is why I thought I could actually
walk in there maybe do something yeah
yeah
you I think you could because you could
just yeah you just look up your kind of
what the two lists are online and just
go with something like that that makes
sense but no I didn't nah didn't manage
to get that done but no not not really
involved in anything else outside of
fortnite that's just me you must have
traveled quite a lot during like your
Pokemon go content phase then yes yeah
we caught all the Regionals right all
the ones he had to go like America and
Japan for oh my God because you made
content doing that being like I'm gonna
go on a flight now to go and get a
Pokemon go from Japan 100. that's the
whole that's what's taking me what was
it was like far-fetched you could only
catch in Japan that's it yeah it was the
European one was it Taurus or Mr mime
and Kangaskhan was Australia yeah yeah
so I did did a bit of traveling there
yeah did did all of them did your
Around the World in 80 Days funded by
Pokemon go right well it's actually even
better because I think I was like
Gamescom so it was like and I was with
there with the EA playing Battlefield so
I was like I was doing that and then
doing this as well right um because
they're still running a second Channel
playing other games okay but uh yeah no
lots of lots of traveling and how many
countries did you end up pinning up
purity for Pokemon go
can you even remember I can't honestly
it's gonna be at least it's gonna be at
least six I reckon okay yeah America
Canada Japan I mean do we count
Australia not really I'm Already There
Germany UK and then there was some I
think Dubai as well what do you think of
the UK yeah I actually really like the
UK yeah that's that's a whole take yeah
I like the people there what are you
talking about okay we're talking people
ranking I would say and I think it's
because people right let's break for you
okay that's fine
so I feel like because like bless up the
queen like Australia Canada and UK
people like just gel the most yeah like
yeah I get on with everybody like I
lived in Canada for like about a year
everyone there super friendly super nice
yeah yeah uh UK feels like Sydney in
some aspects yeah it feels like City but
worse like yes so very
[Music]
with the sidemen
um and like they're always up to some
crazy mad [__] like they've been on a
run for a long time so it's always good
to hang out with those guys like I
honestly just have a lot of fun when I
go to the UK I guess yeah yeah I mean UK
and Australia is very close culturally I
would say especially local people uh and
I'm just like every time I meet on
Australian uh and go to Australia I was
like oh this is what the UK could be
like if we were happy
unlike to me like Australia British
people are like a step like if we're
tearing the tier list it's like British
people stepped down from Australians
because they're just less happy okay but
what who's asked here in this who's
Esther
ing people yeah yeah I think it's just
tearing a nationality
oh God is that racist
I'm white so I can only do white cats
well then amongst the white countries
it's like it's like to me as a Southeast
Asian I'm like my like I've seen so much
like similarities where hang out with
like Latin America people it's like it's
like you know Aussies UK New Zealand
Canada they all jail well I feel like
Southeast Asian and Latin America people
yeah it's just like yeah yeah also it
fits like a glove as well sure
um yeah I don't know what else though
yeah what about your Japanese side who'd
you get along the most with as uh from
you like your Japanese side uh well
considering how xenophobic we are we
only really hang out with Japanese
people
because like everybody else is out here
according to Japan
yeah yeah but actually you've actually
been to Japan right yeah yeah so uh I
lived in uh now here's the thing I think
I was talking to you last night but I
say Osaka yeah but you say it I thought
he said Osaka yeah I was like I I think
I was just in the accident the way I say
it and I'm like and I'm like what you
used to be wear out old Studio was
inside time and then and the local was
like what side yeah
you said yeah no yes I was in Osaka for
it doesn't sound like you're saying yeah
yeah yeah so what wait what's up why why
also
um so at the time like uh the girl I was
dating she got a job out there and I was
like I can do this anywhere I can make
content anywhere
um and I love Japan the few times I went
for Pokemon I was like absolutely just
loved it so I was like yeah I could do
this so got one of those visas that
allowed me like a working holiday for a
year and then just moved over got an
Airbnb and
set up a computer upstairs in this
little concrete castle and then
off we go I was a recording
YouTube videos with in a presumably a
small Japanese apartment with neighbors
and stuff how was that yeah I didn't get
any noise compliance you didn't I didn't
I'd like to think it was very soundproof
like concrete I don't know this is it
though you're right because I was very
conscious of that I did not want to be
that guy coming in just shouting playing
fortnite yeah yeah because that's what I
was doing
um Brad just doing the streaming thing
at the time as well so it was kind of
just get hours in
um but no man that was like that was so
much fun and then that got cut short
because of covert I was like I gotta get
back home I gotta so how long were you
there for that I was only there for I
think two and a half three months oh wow
yeah we went there long yeah and I was
meant to be there for a full year and I
got cut short and now I can't get that
Visa again how's your how's your
experience in Japan I loved it man it
was so much fun like just getting to
like explore different towns like every
weekend like yeah even just running
around Osaka and just finding all these
new different places
suck is great as well because like
unlike people in Tokyo I feel just like
people in Osaka just like very a lot
more like stranger friendly yeah like
they're a lot more comfortable I think
like not just with foreigners but just
like with people they don't know yeah
and just like a lot more like open like
if you go up to someone in Osaka and
just like start chatting with them more
times than in Tokyo they're just like
yeah okay I'll engage in this
conversation you know [__] have have
a bit of beer yeah a lot less English
though and for me really still don't
really speak Japanese yeah
um did you did you end up picking up any
Japanese at all like just enough to get
by you know we ran Google Translate for
the most but like you know like uh you
know yarigato yeah I love hearing
Australian accent
that's all you need to know yeah pretty
much that's pretty much then is the the
thing you say the most yes it really is
it really is they've got their
everything yeah I heard you had a had a
famous uh had a favorite Ramen joint as
well okay so we're talking about this in
the break we got this this is the the
trash tank I guess is that ichiron is
actually good yeah yeah it's actually
good yeah these guys are these guys
people in Japan love it they go crazy no
it's like the most mid-rise
it's good why do you think it's so
popular in Japan it's not just tourists
it's really really popular because Japan
because Japanese people will [__]
form a line on any mediocrity if it's
sold well enough wow they will like
there's so many like there's so many
places where it's like why is there a
line forming in front of this thing that
the common understanding is that it's
kind of mid as hell like at our old
office right we had we had a Burger King
like right near our station okay that
was a line forming okay the [__]
Burger King because there was a new
burger that was coming out and I'm like
what well Japanese people just like line
up for anything that's new yeah yeah I
remember seeing like several lines
outside of McDonald's as well several
times I would like I was gonna say I
really liked Japanese McDonald's
Japanese McDonald's is good Japanese
McDonald's is good but it's not
something I'd be like
everything
I'm lining up for McDonald's there are
very few things I would like line up for
because I don't know like maybe it's
like when I've been getting older but if
I'm hungry I I just want food like now
yeah I I don't like yeah I don't like
lining up there's like have you seen
those tick tocks whatever they were like
this is the best onigiri place in Japan
and it's like a two-hour line for a
[__] onigiri that's what I'm saying
like Japanese
oh it's like the Rice Rice Bowl ah
people will line up two hours just to
get a [__] Rice Bowl yeah like
recently there's been this boom in Japan
of uh like onigiri like specific uh like
places yeah and they're supposedly it's
like oh it's it's a there's a different
type of rice ball like we specialize in
rice balls I'm like how much can you
change
yeah it's good uh but like that's the
thing is like I feel Japan is is this
has this common idea where it's like
they see a line or they see a crowd and
the first instinct is oh I should
probably join in on it because it's
probably something that a I don't want
to miss out on or B is something really
good because it's like it must be good
if there's a line in front of it yeah
but then there's this kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy of like well
even the people are just lining up
because the line is there like they're
not actually thinking about well is it
actually good or if is the product even
worth lining up for and I feel ichiran
is a big culprit in that because each
run and a lot of these like big chains
do this thing where they just like make
the outside look flashy as [__] yeah to
be like hey we have great Ramen just you
know blasting it out into the
stratosphere and the Japanese people
look at and be like well that looks kind
of sick start lining up and then the
line forms I think one of the things
that ichiran has done if you I mean you
can use Google pictures of it um you
know ramen places are traditionally very
like dingy yeah kind of like it's
definitely yeah it's due to smell of
smoke you know it's not like them you
know and when you walk in and you look
white as [__] it's just like they're
like they're all just like
yeah yeah like yeah there's a few things
that ichiron does well especially if
you're a tourist which is why I think
it's so popular it's one uh like you can
it's it's so easy to order there's no
kind of like barrier to be like Oh I'm
going to this also like made for
Japanese people they don't want to talk
okay yeah yeah exactly exactly well most
ramen places they just have you know
little vending machine where you can get
tickets and then you just give it to the
dude right but even like yeah even like
trying to I guess trying to figure out
the ticket machine is kind of like
daunting if you've never been to Japan
before you don't know how it works the
one I feel the one thing that each run
did really really well was that like
they're the one of the best when it
comes to like customizing yeah that's it
I always want to add like 10 more cloves
of garlic and it's true and you can just
add a [__] ton of garlic yeah like they
give you that option so that's like the
big selling point of ramen but I'm like
just because the options for
customizability is there doesn't mean
it's good I love it I think it tastes
[__] bombs yeah I I tried to hit it
like at least once a week when I was in
football
I remember like I would finish the
street because 24 hours as well at least
one mine was 24 hours yeah
um but it was like hit like a four or
five hour stream it was like it was
winter too when I was there like early
in the year yeah oh 100 I was like just
just bang like a five hour stream it's 2
A.M I'm gonna hit you on and I got my
bike bike down each run and I think it
was in a bit of a interesting place
because a lot of guys in suits you right
yes
but it was like I should probably not be
here I I don't know I I was like it was
a bit Saucy like because it was in this
District where I think also like the
strip clubs were as well yeah yeah and
it was like just a lot of guys in suits
like on the what are they they were like
in on the corner of the intersection
like the touts they're like they're
trying to get you into places yeah but
it was just weird also I think I know
the area you're talking about and I
guarantee the majority of those dudes in
suits were probably Yakuza members
and there we go yeah and I'm just
walking through white guy on a bike 2AM
going to get some itchy on yeah yeah I I
I was thinking maybe it might be
something going on here but like you
know I just
my equivalent of I guess going to Japan
and going to like ichiran for me would
be like going to America and going to
McDonald's you know it's kind of like
you go to a country where there's so
much great choice of [__] burgers and
fast food and you choose McDonald's so
so in Japan this is kind of anomaly
where like reviews of places are pretty
consistently around the same score but
for ramen they're always lower like
consistently they a four-star Ramen
place is quite uncommon on Google Maps
but they'll always be four star like
other restaurants right and so
and I realized I'm like yeah because a
lot of Rama placing trainers [__]
suck like sometimes they'll give you the
chashu the pork yeah and it's just the
worst piece of meat I've ever had in my
life it's gross it's fatty it doesn't
taste of anything and I'm like dude it's
sure never [__] this up yeah because
they've been around for so long that
they've like able to engineer it
perfectly this is how chains come around
ramen shops in Japan are like some of
the fastest some of them are good some
of them are good some of them I like the
ones some of them some of the men I
don't know what they've done of that
pork I thought they abused it before
they killed it the ramen shops in
general in Japan are like the the most
competitive scene yeah yeah Japan like a
Ramen Shop could be there and then like
a month later it'd be gone well it's
because the margins are so low like
you're selling a bowl of ramen for like
you know you can't sell all wrong with
more than 1200 313 uh 1300 Yen yeah
because no one does that no that doesn't
give you a lot of time to make money